hey let's go prize money today we're
playing 3d bridges and I bet what you're
thinking right now is holy [ __ ] where
can i get this amazing game it looks so
good my god hold your horses
let's just play first and then you can
maybe check it out all right
oh my god what am I looking at okay
let's click start start
best game alright well I've been playing
this for about a couple minutes and I
already have an intense urge to in my
life okay
here we go building bridges it's loading
I know a thing or two about building
bridges so this should be easy peasy
lemon potassium so we want to start by
building this there okay okay this is
nice oh my god
3d bridges is all full okay let's build
the road
how does okay that's a pretty good
bridge let's see if this works no okay
okay it's a new day it's a new life
yes okay this is a pretty solid bridge I
would say so now we build the land
that's pretty good land okay I don't see
why not
okay you know what I think we got it now
start
pretty good this is not just bridging
this is boring
think I'm starting to understand how
this works this game wasn't hard enough
already
oh my [ __ ] god
shut up how does this how does this work
what even is this to follow what start
what is that oh my god then I just
[ __ ] built a [ __ ] Road did I just
do that as a strong independent woman
why why am I doing this I have a
personal agenda with this [ __ ] now
cook it there and then you click there
and then you click there and then you
from there it's that a [ __ ] Road yeah
that is the [ __ ] Road resident have
you ever [ __ ] the road before [ __ ] what
how does that even make any [ __ ]
sense how does the one in the [ __ ]
middle stay how how are they made of
just kill yourself just suicide then
[ __ ] sense just kill yourself ok now
we've done this we play some [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass ropes and [ __ ] alright
this ladies and rose is how you build a
[ __ ] bridge now this is fine
that's fine no big deal no big deal are
you
holy [ __ ]
it's the best [ __ ] bridge Oh God okay
okay
you know yeah yeah I can work with this
I can work with this okay
stay up stay stay the [ __ ] up yeah
that's right you're gonna go but Dad you
white your pants
go almost almost dead at that time
almost did it go go go
it's like I find one solution and a
million others occur okay
so I've spent 40 [ __ ] minutes
look at my resources zero I perfect that
it I didn't just do it i perfected that
[ __ ] [ __ ] look how [ __ ] stable
that is this is say this is our moment
I'm so scared just go just go ah you
[ __ ] you know we can do it we can do it
we can do it we can I hit the pole so
far so good so far so good
yes almost there oh my god there's hope
there is hope for the children
yeah
my god they told me nothing was
impossible congratulations you reach the
stern point and oh my god we have to go
back we have to go [ __ ] back this is
ridiculous
please for the love of God please you're
not being reasonable
oh god it's dangling like a [ __ ] big
penis stop dangling Oh God
okay oh god what have we learned today
what have we [ __ ] learned what have we
learned today
my sweet children I'm gonna go and have
an ice-cream and rethink my life thank
you for watching this video if you
enjoyed it
live your life I don't know what the
[ __ ] to tell you main yes hello hello
this is crack hello yes hello yes